بدرجات متفاوته يستمر القتال في شتى مناطق
الشرق الاوكراني لكن جبهه الحرب الرئيسيه
تظل باخموت الواقعه تحت النار منذ نحو
ثمانيه اشهر وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت
في بيان السيطره على مناطق اخرى في
المدينه
قواتنا تواصل هجماتها على محور دونيتسك
وفي الجانب الغربي من مدينه بخموت سيطرت
قواتنا على اربعه احياء كما تمكنت الوحدات
الهجوميه بدعم من القوات المحموله جوا من
دفع القوات الاوكرانيه الى الجزء الغربي
من مدينه ضخمه وقد نشرت ميليشيا فاجنر
التي تقود الهجوم مقاطع فيديو اظهرت
انتشار قناصتها داخل مباني شاهقه خلال
المعارك الدائره هناك
لكن ما يبدو تفوقا روسيا في بخموت حتى
الان تربكه تصريحات جديده لقائد المجموعه
لوح فيها بسحب بعض قواته من الجبهه اذا لم
تنهي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مشكله نقص
الذخيره وتلك مصاعب يفاقمها اكثر تصميم
القوات الاوكرانيه على التصدي للهجوم
الروسي وشنها هجمات مضاده كهذه التي
يظهرها فيديو نشره الجيش الاوكراني مؤكدا
ان مقاتليه استعادوا السيطره على محور في
بخموت كانت تسيطر عليه القوات الروسيه بعد
ان تمكنوا من قتل عدد من جنودها واسرع
اخرين تلك المستجدات الميدانيه وغيرها
دفعت القياده السياسيه في اوكرانيا الى
الذهاب بعيدا في اتخاذ مزيد من القرارات
الاستراتيجيه
سيفيني
بصراحه الدعم الغربي سيساعدنا كثيرا لكننا
نتفهم ايضا انه لا يمكننا ربط الهجوم
المضاد بالخارج ولهذا السبب سنبدا الهجوم
المضاده قبل تسلم طائرات اف 16 او طرازات
اخرى لن نسمح لروسيا بالاستفاده من حقيقه
حاجتنا الى شهرين للتدريب على الطائره لا
لن يحدث هذا سنبدا ونمضي قدما
الهجوم الاوكراني المزمع لم يمنع زيلينسكي
من التذكير بمقترحه للسلام المكون من عشر
نقاط لانهاء الحرب وهو ما ناقشه هاتفيا
الاحد مع نظيره الفرنسي
بالنسبه للمتحدثه باسم القياده الجنوبيه
في الجيش الاوكراني فان استعداد كيف
لهجومها المضاد في شرق البلاد بدا السبت
بقصف طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه منشاه لتخزين
النفط في مدينه
تابعه لشبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا
عام 2014
والهجوم المرتقب جاءت مؤشراته ايضا من
موسكو التي اعلنت تعيين الجنرال
نائبا لوزير الدفاع الروسي مكلفا
بالامدادات الماديه والتقنيه للقوات
المسلحه بدلا من الجنرال ميخائيل
ميزنتيزيف الذي قاد الحصار الطويل على
مدينه ماريو بولس الساحليه في جنوب شرق
اوكرانيا